welcome everybody thanks for watching
welcome to the the car cast as I call it
now and hope hope you've had a great
morning so far so you've probably
noticed that over the last several
decades or so our country has developed
a system and it's a really stupid system
but it's our system and it works like
this virtually every 18-year olds who
graduates high school no matter what
their strengths are no matter what the
weakness is no matter what they want to
do with their life even if they have no
idea what they want to do with their
life it doesn't matter what we say to
all of them no matter what is you should
all go to a four-year college you should
all go and spend seventy thousand
dollars or more buying this education
and then you're gonna spend the next
four years or longer hanging out at an
institution of higher learning where
yeah you'll go to class and you'll take
some tests but most of the time you'll
be partying drinking playing beer pong
having sex so it'll be kind of like a
fun vacation and once you emerge from
that at the age of 22 23 24 25 you will
be drowning in a river of debt and booze
but you will have no practical
experience doing anything of value you
will not have you will not have learned
how to live as an adult you want to paid
bills you know you won't be you won't be
doing all the things that you that you
do when you when you live on your own
not in a dorm room or something so
you're not gonna have any of those
skills will you'll have no skill
whatsoever but you will have this piece
of paper that you drove yourself into
debt to acquire and this is how young
adults are emerging into the world and
we consider it perfectly normal emerge
finally into the world with no
experience no skill nothing on the
resume but with a mountain of debt and a
piece of paper but what happens what do
we find because we've pushed everyone
into this field and so everyone's coming
out with a degree with a four-year
degree so it doesn't really mean
anything anymore all it means if you
have a four-year bachelor's degree it
doesn't mean you accomplished anything
it doesn't mean that you're particularly
smart I mean no offense those who have
it but it doesn't it doesn't actually
all it means is that you were able to
stay in college until of
actually you got the degree it doesn't
it didn't require necessarily a lot of
work or intelligence or or or fortitude
to to purchase it just basically
required money which you didn't have but
you took the debt anyway so people are
going out there emerging into the to the
working world and discovering that well
this piece of paper doesn't really
amount to much won't get me a job so
then you go back to school to get
another degree hoping that the debt from
that degree will pay off the debt from
the first degree that did you nothing
and if that doesn't work then go back
for another degree and basically just
stay in school until you're 75 and what
do we do we just continue to fortify and
to reinforce this artificial societal
construct we hear a lot about artificial
social constructs well gender is not a
social construct but this is it's a
social construct that we've created now
where you basically have to have a PhD
in like psychology in order to get a job
working in the HR department at a target
scored a target store
actually now that's it that's an
artificial need we have created an
artificial need for a degree that you
don't actually need a business degree to
go sit in the cubicle and type
information into a computer all day you
could learn how to do that in in one
evening you know you could go you could
spend three hours one evening and they
could give you the basics of it and you
can learn the whole job you don't need
four years and the degree to figure that
out so for the the massed vast majority
of jobs that require a four-year degree
the requirement is artificial we've just
decided that you need it but you don't
actually need it now ironically as we
have inflated this artificial need for a
degree colleges have become or should be
becoming more and more irrelevant
because the actual act of Education that
is acquiring knowledge well that you can
do more and more on your own human
beings are more empowered now than ever
before
to acquire knowledge completely on their
own
because what we all have is we all have
this we have this thing this device and
we carry around in our pocket and yes it
can be a portal into a into a cesspool
of Filth and stupidity but if we use it
the right way with discipline it can
also give us access to basically the
accumulated knowledge of all mankind all
of the knowledge and information in the
world you have in your pocket whatever
information or knowledge you can acquire
at college I could find it here or in a
book at a library it hasn't always been
that way but now it is but as college
should be more irrelevant than ever
made it artificially more relevant than
ever so that's basically that's the
that's the system that we've established
and there are many problems with this
system I have criticized in many
different ways and we could talk about
all those aspects I'm sure I'll talk
about them again in the future but what
I want to focus on now is you know the
the biggest problem with the system that
we have in place now of requiring
everyone to go to these colleges it's
not even the financial aspect it's not
that these degrees are basically
worthless now it's not that the biggest
problem is at least from the perspective
of a Christian the biggest problem is
what the college system is doing to the
souls of our children the college system
is in the education system generally not
just the college
destroying the souls of our children we
are surrendering our kids into the hands
of lunatics and our kids are paying a
price for that and it's a price much
steeper than tuition now the latest
example of this from a couple of days
ago I wrote about yesterday I'm sure you
saw this woman named the Ron de girar
she's a professor at Fresno State excuse
me she's an English professor and she
was a gloating on Twitter over the death
of Barbara Bush she said she's a you
know Barbara Bush is a piece of ass a
racist someone and so forth which
there's nothing remarkable about a
mentally ill Twitter troll using the
death of a famous person to get
attention but in this case it's
especially disturbing because she's a
professor not just the professor but
she's an English professor apparently
yet she's ranting and tweeting with
terrible grammar and punctuation she's
tweeting these insults and a 92 year old
dead woman and this is not new territory
for Fresno State by the way last year
just last year a different professor got
into trouble because he tweeted that
Trump must hang and there are many many
more examples of left-wing lunacy from
college professors and we could be here
all day listing all of them because
there are hundreds of examples a day
because liberal professors outnumber
according to them to the latest survey
on this liberal professors outnumber
conservative professors by a ratio of
twelve to one which is not surprising
but still incredible twelve to one
number conservatives
so again the question
why are we sending our kids to these
institutions
why are we spending exorbitant amounts
of money for the privilege of having
them in East India in these institutions
what why are we paying tens of thousands
of dollars a year for Ron de girar think
about that if you're sending your kid to
Fresno State you are paying all of that
money for Ron de girar and her ilk now
there are some good colleges yeah there
are a few good colleges but the issue is
that we as Christians we are not
relegating ourselves and our children to
those few good colleges if we did these
liberal colleges wouldn't exist
they couldn't exist without us we're
keeping them in business we're handing
over we're handing just hand over fist
we're giving them tons of cash to keep
them in business we are trying our
hardest to keep these schools and
business I shared with you in the piece
yesterday a woman emailed me just last
week I get emails like this all the time
and I feel bad when I read them but it's
also a little frustrating I got a I got
a email from a woman who's very
distraught because her son who was
raised Christian she thought he was a
you know good solid Christian sends him
off to UCLA after two years at UCLA he
is now a liberal atheist not a huge
surprise as I said I feel bad for her I
pray for her son but it does
the question why did you send your son
to UCLA what what good possibly could
have come of it
I'm not talking about what good it could
have done to his career or his resume
and even there it's it's dubious
but what good will it do for his soul is
the question
this is the thing that we should be
focused on as parents
you know our primary job is to protect
the souls of our kids and to fortify
them in their faith
to try to make of them virtuous people
that's our primary job the education
system and especially a lot of these
colleges they are they are determined to
do the opposite they are determined to
take your kid and to undo everything you
have spent the last 18 years doing
why would you why would you not only
willingly accept that but pay them to do
it
just understand this college is never
gonna become cheaper it's never gonna
become less artificially necessary
schools will never stop being hot beds
of liberal insanity
until we show a willingness to stop
participating in this charade the it
people wonder well why is it you know
why are the colleges getting any better
why it's just getting worse and worse
they have no incentive to get better we
can complain all we want about our the
liberal bias on college campuses
complain all you want if you then turn
around and give them $50,000 and your
kid it won't matter your complaints mean
nothing
what they'll do they take your money and
your kid and they laugh in your face no
I've heard all the arguments I've heard
parents will say well you know we got to
fight the system and we got to send our
kids in there and reclaim the system
you're not reclaiming the system by
giving them money and your kid let me
fight the system by giving them $50,000
now I think we have a confusion here
it's like if you're fighting the enemy
and and so what you do is you you you
you carpet bomb them with just bags of
cash and you know food and weapons no
that's that's that's not how you fight
the systems you know what you do to
fight the system you take your money and
your kid out of it you starve it is what
you do and besides which because I know
people say well you know what I've I've
raised my kid right he's 18
and so you know I can send him into that
environment he can withstand it well a
couple of problems with that
the one that I already mentioned that
well that's not your your only
sustaining and feeding the system when
you do that you're contributing to the
problem you're giving the school no
incentive whatsoever to stop with the
liberal bias if they see that you just
going to give them your money anyway and
your kid what they have no incentive
number two education you know education
it's not just about giving information
it's not just about acquiring knowledge
it's also about forming human beings
Aristotle would have said that education
is about making virtuous people so it's
about forming people it's about forming
them in their virtue and forming a
belief system we could talk all we want
about how we want you know objective
education no bias that's impossible it
doesn't exist one way or another in
education is gonna have a worldview
attached to it so if you're spending all
of this money don't you want to spend it
so that your kid is formed in the proper
worldview why would you spend it so
he'll be formed in a worldview at odds
with the one you tried to instill in him
that is the correct and truthful one
education should not be a war it should
not be an attack why should it's not
fair to our kids that's our version of
educating them is just throw them into
this of environment where they'll just
be attacked non-stop every second of the
day from every angle and they'll just be
in and you'll just be like torn to
shreds and they'll just have confusion
and insanity heaped on them that's not
what education is supposed to be yes
eventually we are supposed to be
fortified enough in our faith and in our
knowledge that we can go into the world
and and fight you know fight for Christ
and Fright fight for the truth education
is supposed to form is that supposed to
help form us as the kind of people who
can go out and complete that mission but
if a person is
educated they're not going to be formed
enough to be the salt and light in the
world and if a child's education or a
young adults education is against them
is like conspiring against them at all
times well that's not an education
that's gonna properly form them that's
an education where most of what they
hear they're gonna have to resist and
reject but that's not what education is
supposed to be not to mention the vast
majority of 18 year olds no matter what
you think of your kid and I'm sure you
have a wonderful kid but no matter what
you think of your kid the vast majority
of them are not equipped for just the
onslaught of hostility and temptation
which is the biggest part of this
are not equipped for that they're not
equipped to to now live in this
environment of constant moral hostility
and and temptation they're not equipped
and the proof is in the pudding I mean
if it actually worked this way that you
know you send your kid to some liberal
cesspool and it helps to form them as
strong fiery Christians if that actually
worked there I should be able to look
around and see a culture filled with
strong fiery Christians that's not what
I see I see the vast majority of
Christians who go into college and come
out like this woman's son come out
basically liberal atheists that's what
happens with most of them so this plan
of you know send them in and trial by
fire it's not working it has not worked
maybe we need to rethink this plan a
little bit wait let me ask you would you
send your son into a strip club to hand
out tracts
what would you say well you know I trust
my son here you go here you go he's 18
years old here you go here's some tracks
going to that strip club and hand them
out to the certainly there are a lot of
people inside that strip club
who are lost and who need to hear the
truth of Christ would you send your son
in if you would I would say you're crazy
there's a much much much greater chance
that that this occasion for sin that you
have just tossed him into will claim him
and destroy him there's a much greater
chance of that then there is that he
will you know convert all the heathens
in the strip club our first job as
parents is not to the world it's not to
society it's not to the system it's not
you know it's not that we should our
first job is not to make sure that our
kids can compete in the global
marketplace our first
is to our children's souls
now personally I don't care if my kids
like six-figure salaries I don't care
what they do for a living
as long as it's moral I honestly don't
I'm being now I know my kids are young
you can say it's easy for me to say fine
hold me to it down the line I really
don't care if my kids end up doesn't
matter to me I really don't care they
get a blue-collar job they get a
customer service job they get a job that
pays them a million dollars a year
doesn't matter
I'd probably prefer one of the other two
options because a million dollars a year
I mean we're told in the gospel and it's
very difficult for a rich man to get to
heaven
which I don't care about that my dream
for their lives has nothing to do with
income or social status or any of that I
just want them to be good Christians
especially when I look at this world and
I look at the culture and I look at all
of these
kids whose parents thought that they
were going out to be salt and light in
the world but actually quickly defected
and became one of the heathens when I
look at that I say you know I I just
want my kids to be good Christians if
that's all they ever become well then
they will be far greater successes than
the vast majority of their peers
are a few colleges I'm not saying that
there are no colleges there are a few
colleges that could potentially help
them in that pursuit this pursuit of
holiness which is what we're supposed to
be pursuing as Christians and I would
consider spending money I would consider
spending a lot of money on on a school
like that but I wouldn't spend a single
dime
on one of these liberal schools which is
most of them
in fact I would spend every dime I have
to keep them out of that school a school
like that
I just I feel increasingly that it's
it's just not fair
what we're doing to our kids and what
we're expecting of them
of just throwing them into the culture
without any preparation at all and just
saying well you figure it out you know
this is a whole different topic
for a different video but Christians
today in this culture are they it seems
like we are so terrified of extricated
ourselves and so resistant to the idea
that we should extricate ourselves from
any aspect of the culture whatsoever if
you try to as a Christian family if you
try to establish any barrier of
separation at all between yourself and
the world you're gonna have all these
other Christians saying ah stop you
can't put them in a bubble in the world
not of the world
and so what do they do they can they
send their kids to the liberal schools
they let their kids watch whatever they
want on TV listen to whatever music they
want do whatever they want online watch
whatever movies I mean their kids just
are completely immersed in the culture
the parents making no effort to insulate
them whatsoever which they claim they
pretend is well I'm trying to equip them
from the world no you're just lazy is
what you are
you're just lazy and also you are
addicted to those things in the world
and and so you don't want to cut any of
that off but this is it's it's that's a
crazy strategy we need to have if you
want to call it a bubble call it a
bubble I don't care we need to have a
protective bubble of sorts around our
kids while they are kids and while we
are raising them and bringing them up in
the faith all right we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody I'll talk
to you tomorrow